- I feel like I'm at the worst
like wedding cake tasting
(man laughs)
in the whole world.
- It's like the wedding of the apocalypse.
(upbeat music)
- When I think of survival food
I automatically think I'm gonna eat a bug.
- Survival food is what you keep in your
apocalypse bunker, like a can
of beans, or some Twinkies.
- Fish that you grabbed with
your hands from a stream
when you're lost.
- See I'm a past boy scout
and survival food is like MREs,
which is meals ready to eat.
- I'm very nervous, I have no idea
what's in this food,
what we're about to eat.
- It doesn't look bad.
- Yeah.
- Oh so it's just a
packet that's freeze dried
and then you add water into it.
- These chunks look like cat food to me.
- Survival food or
probably college food too.
(woman laughs)
Did a lot at college.
- Cheers.
- This is pretty good.
- I mean it's got flavor.
- The chicken kinda tastes like fish.
- Maybe airplane good.
- I mean, I'm like going
back for another bite.
- Right.
- I mean if I was on a budget,
if I only had a few dollars.
- I think I need it now.
(woman and man laugh)
- Can I eat it all?
Alright, it's pretty good.
- I would definitely eat
this chicken and rice
before I would eat a person.
- Okay, same.
- It doesn't look like
any food I've ever seen.
- I feel like this looks
like astronaut food, maybe.
- Are we gonna break a tooth?
- I think if a crumb
cake and a rock fucked...
(record screeches)
- Is it weird I imagined that in my head?
- Oh my, it's so hard.
- It's really hard.
- A little tough to bite into.
But it's got flavor.
- Like a strawberry Laffy Taffy
but like someone like messed up
and forgot to put all
the strawberry in there.
- I don't know it doesn't actually...
- No.
- It wants to.
- It's got like chalk flavor.
- I can't even break it in half.
- It is unbreakable.
- I'm a big dude, I can't even.
- I guess if like the zombies are coming,
you could throw this at them
and it would like hurt them a little bit.
- That is very true.
This could also be doubled as a weapon.
- Is this cheese?
- It looks like the crust of like a pie
that didn't want to finish.
- It looks like a fry and
Parmesan cheese fucked.
- Awe, that's pretty good.
- Yeah.
- It's softer.
- Much softer than that other thing.
- This is something you'd find
in like the 99 cent store.
- This is weirdly good.
I feel like I would like snack on this.
- If you had some peanut butter on this,
that would probably be really good.
- I'd probably go and look for some fish
in the stream or something.
- I think I would probably
eat this while I was looking
for the fish in the stream.
- This looks like the bag
that dog treats come in.
(man and woman laugh)
- What?
- What is in this?
- Is it a bug?
(man and woman laugh)
- Survival tabs?
- Full meals in one little piece of candy.
- It smells like lip gloss for children.
- Do you smell lip gloss
for children often?
- Yeah.
- This is looks like what I throw in...
like with my laundry.
- I ain't got a chewy.
- It's bad.
- It's real bad.
- I don't like this one.
- It's very chalky like it looks.
Gets better as you nibble.
- Crunchy.
- It's a creaminess, but
you're like why is it creamy
and there's nothing creamy about it
when it was in my hand.
- I'd rather eat a person than eat this,
like I'm gonna eat my neighbor
before I'm eating these creamy tabs.
- There are some nutrients in it.
- My mouth feels weird now.
- My mouth feels like a survivor.
- You can survive three weeks without
having any food in your body.
- I could survive a few hours.
- I can't even like
install an A/C you know?
Although I will say that like
pretty okay with like eating bugs.
- After you've been hiking
for like eight or 10 hours,
you would literally eat like dog crap.
- Would you?
- People have eaten people before
because they're hungry.
- Cause they hiked for eight hours?
- Cause they had to survive,
cause they hiked for eight hours,
you know I have a sensational appetite.